it's great to welcome back to the
program Michael Wood jr. who's a police
management expert activist president of
veterans stand as well as former
Baltimore Police Commander Michael it's
great to have you back on the program
and the timing really couldn't be better
although I don't know if better is the
right word to use here you reacted to
this speech that Donald Trump gave in
front of a law-enforcement crowd where
he sort of jokingly said you know it's
really not a bad idea to kind of rough
up suspects that you have in custody if
they've been accused or are suspected of
having committed a serious enough crime
which to me it was disturbing on so many
levels not the least of which that being
arrested for something is not the same
as having been convicted of something
regardless of how serious it is so take
it from the top I mean what was your
reaction to the comments from President
Trump well thanks for having me again
and I mean the basic idea that's really
bothering me when it comes to what Trump
is saying is that that's the seed that
we kind of have in our culture that we
aren't looking at the command structure
we aren't looking at the actual power
that's set up and incentivizing all this
and setting these balls in motion what
we end up doing is we blame the officer
that actually bangs the head on the door
but this whole thing is a part of a
culture that comes down and when you are
the president then you are talking down
to police officers or whoever's out on
the street to execute your will to go
and do something that is against the
basic premise of professional law
enforcement even if even as American law
enforcement is there is not a best
practices book or a police expert out
there that's going to say you treat
convicted suspects this way let alone
citizens who are proven innocent who are
innocent until proven guilty so there
there is this systemic attitude where
policing ends up encapsulating like what
America really is and I'm anti Trump
just as much as I'm anti sneezing but I
don't blame this
for my sneeze like he is a product of us
and if we can't see that that this
really demonstrates what America is in
it in its its soul and we need to fight
that then I don't really know what
people are looking at there's a similar
idea that we sometimes hear when it
comes to the sentencing of individuals
convicted of child sex abuse and some
other crimes sometimes this idea that
hey their punishment will be made worse
because they might get sexually
assaulted in our prisons or in our jails
and when I hear that I say that's not
something that we should be applauding
because it's going to make their time
worse that's sort of an inability of our
prison system to keep individuals safe
like the fact that you might be sexually
assaulted in prison depending on the
crime that you're convicted of that's
something that we should be concerned
about not cheering as part of some
additional justice is there a similarity
between these two ideas we should be
incredibly concerned and I'm really
happy you brought that up and have made
that connection that you see in our
prison system and again that is America
right we say to ourselves let's punish
this person let's put them into a system
well they will have injustice in
humanity they will they will be
assaulted and have all this punishment
go down upon them despite the fact that
punishment isn't going to do anything to
make the situation better and then we
are trying to like change the prison
system and say criminal justice needs to
be better at the same time applauding
when someone we don't like goes into an
inhumane system we do the same thing
with police like as much as as I want to
see accountability in policing there is
no justice in sending a police officer
to an inhumane and in just system so we
have to really look in ourselves to
figure out like what do we really want
policing to be are we the country that's
gonna stand up and say we want to be a
punitive thing we don't care about
science despite the fact that every
meta-analysis of scientific literature
will show you that punishment does not
equal a deterrent
we are still so hell-bent on being a
violent society that wants to do even
thinks that these things would work like
we're going down a pathway that is
incredibly concerning to me and
obviously it is to you
you use the word systemic a little bit
earlier in the interview and I think if
we sort of imagine a spectrum you might
have those completely on one side who
believe that the issues with police
violence and police brutality are 100%
systemic and that there's very little
blame to place on the individual
officers on the other side of that
spectrum you might imagine those who
believe this is merely a few bad apples
only the individual police officers are
to blame here and there is nothing
systemic going on the truth is probably
sort of somewhere in the middle of that
but I want to ask you where do you think
it is in other words how much of this
problem is the individuals how much of
the problem is systemic
I mean I'm thrown out of [ __ ] Park
number but I'm gonna go with probably 95
to 99 percent is completely systemic the
the way I can kind of encapsulate this
on an individual intimate level here is
that I grew up trying to be race blind I
mean I grew up in the age of information
in mixed neighborhoods and I had this
idea to myself that as a police officer
what I was going to do is be impartial I
was gonna follow the letter of the law I
was gonna follow a departmental policies
to a tee and it man it took me a while
but I've realized eventually at the end
that all of my actions of what I was
empirically doing on the street was was
racist
it was Presidents against a society it
was inhumane it was it was in just and
all of those things that I was doing I
was really looking at the system and
saying if we do this perfectly if we do
this system perfectly then we will have
justice so explain that a little bit
like for example I mean know having
interviewed you before would one example
of what you're talking about be despite
the reality that you went
wanting to be race blind and not
discriminating etc for example by virtue
of the neighborhoods you were policing
the impact of your policing was going to
be effectively racist is that an example
of what you mean yeah that's a good
example or whether I put someone into
bonds or whether I was looking at so I
thought I was a narcotics detective
hunting down narcotics but I wasn't
there was an entire half of that city
which we know empirically without a
doubt then anyone can argue it and I
know it from practical experience the
white communities have just as much
drugs if not more one reason why cocaine
sentencing is much higher is not because
of a racist thing intentionally it's
because cocaine is a white drug and so
white drugs end up having more resources
so a mid-level dealer ends up being much
higher on the scale of being a resource
same damn word I used a second ago but
so those those things that we end up
doing we think this is normal but when
we end up going after the drug did where
do they put me they put me in East and
West Baltimore to go after drug dealers
so I end up going after only the
community because the drug dealing and
drug possession is actually equal if not
more in a rich and white community think
about it drugs are expensive
I mean people with money have more drugs
than people without money this is even
rational but where was I sent to go get
the drugs in redlined
poor neighborhoods to put into an
inhumane system that how's about a
system that they can't / can't do so
it's not like it's not necessarily the
officers fault that when they're doing
that and even if they do it well they
send people into a system so even if you
had a police department that was
operating perfectly they would still be
sending people in handing them off to a
state's attorney who who states
attorneys are blatantly corrupt around
around the country they are incentivized
in that same system so they have the
same problems they're incentivized to
win not for justice so like can we talk
about federal prosecutors ago you better
be aware there's federal prosecutors
they have a 97 percent conviction rate
well they don't have a 97 percent
conviction rate to have a 97 percent
victory rate which means that cases are
plead down or
whatever they do they use a manipulate
power so the day can rise through the
ranks so they don't get incentivized to
do the right thing they get incentivize
for the most convictions to rise up
through the ranks and then prisons are
incentivized to be as efficient as
possible so give people is really little
resources as possible why we're doing
this punishment system so it is this
whole big institution that police
officers are a pawn of is the people
above the street cops that all set this
thing in the motion and don't take any
of the responsibility for it one reason
why you see cops getting away with
committing murders right on camera is
when that these things indict the system
when they indict the system the whole
thing will rally around them to protect
them and get them off like Freddie gray
so I mean that when the officers killed
Freddie gray in Baltimore
no supervisors took accountability for
this so understand this killing what
happened was is is by the court case
anyway he goes into a van and where
they're supposed to be transporting him
to a prison cell they already put them
in there for really sketchy reasons to
begin with but then they bring them out
of the van dead so the whole time this
is a van that doesn't have seatbelts
doesn't have proper supervision doesn't
have cameras in the back doesn't have
any accountability and Freddie gray was
the fourth person to be killed or
paralyzed in the back of those vans just
in recent history but no command members
Kevin Davis doesn't pay a price the
mayor doesn't pay a price nobody has
anything happened to them other than the
individual officer at the bottom who was
really just a pawn all along we've been
speaking with Michael Wood jr. he is a
former Baltimore Police Commander you
can follow him on Twitter at Michael a
Wood jr. and also check out civilian-led
policing dot org Michael always great to
talk to you yeah thanks for having me
David thanks for throwing in those
pictures there we definitely need people
to go to veterans stand and civilian
life policing that is the way you guys
can take something in your own hands and
do something in your community